[Music]
as a child my parents always told me you
could be whatever you want to be you
could do whatever you want to do and you
know that that office that position that
the highest office on the face of the
earth it was something I heard my
parents saying it but I didn't totally
believe it yet I went out in the world
and I carried myself and I held my head
high and I stood there and I look people
in their eyes and I talk to people as if
I was deserving of everything that this
planet has to offer
so I just I really want to say to two
children out there and to two people who
are watching Confucius said one time he
who says he can and he who says he can't
are both usually right so I want to
stand here before you and as I hold this
award I want to give love to my wife and
I want you to keep in your heart just
know that you can notice again so I love
this video
one because I love Will Smith too
because I didn't know Confucius said
that I always attributed that quote
about whether you believe you can and
you can't you're right to Henry Ford and
so I guess for took you from Confucius
so that's very interesting and third the
single most important lesson that my
parents taught me that I'm trying to
pass on to the next generation but my
family as well as few guys believe
nation my extended family is to believe
in yourself like if you believe you can
do something you much more likely to be
able to do it and if you believe that
you can't then you're absolutely right
and so when somebody comes to you and
says I don't believe I can do it then
bill that they never will and so growing
up that's what my parents taught me and
they would always say that I'm Evan
Chris truly Carmichael my mom's lost him
surely I could do anything I wanted and
I remember that I would have that talk
with them every year when I got my
report cards my sisters would get
straight A's and then I would get B's
and C's and we'd always sit down and we
talk about my grades
and instead of scolding me or punishing
me it would always be on the positive
side I always say hey your Yorkist
really Carmichael and you can do
anything that you want and with enough
repetition you know I think when I
received that message to begin the guy
here again but it's sunk in you know
with enough repetition it made me
believe that and by my last year in high
school my own expectations for myself
past what my parents expected of me they
wanted me to get A's and I got straight
A's in high school I got straight 90s in
my last year and I don't know what it
was in that last year of high school
that pushed my own belief system beyond
what my parents expected of me maybe
it's just becoming more grown-up or I
don't know I wish I can kind of go back
or maybe some psychoanalysis and pull
out and be somewhere buried in my
subconscious but I know what's helped me
since is that surrounding myself with
people with idea the resources that make
me think bigger
stretched my belief of what I can do so
you know coming out of high school I
believe I can get straight 90s and I did
it and I got straight 90s and now as I'm
trying to have a bigger impact I want to
help a billion entrepreneurs you want to
first set that goal I felt like a bit of
an impostor like I wanted to do but
didn't know if I could and I had this
internal battle with myself that I
remember bringing to my mastermind group
one month is I don't know if I can do it
I don't know if I believe in myself
enough to do it and so how do you
stretch how do you be able to believe it
because if I don't believe I can hit
that goal then I won't and so for me it
was just continuing to surround myself
with the content with the videos mostly
with the videos with some books but
really some videos being around
successful entrepreneurs doing big
things and I feel like you know what
that billion goal that's not that big
other people are doing way bigger things
if I'm around them more there are a
little bit of magic pixie dust rubs off
on the me to help me do much much much
bigger things
I think whatever goal it is that you
have whatever belief system that you
want to change or me feel like you're
limited in some way and you're angry
about it you want to change it changing
your environment is one of the fastest
ways to do it and so I use the example
of confidence where if you want to be
more confident yes you can read a book
on confidence yes you can watch a video
on eight ways to be more confident that
may give you some practical tactical
things but I think the best way to be
able to break through it is to watch
people being confident whether that's in
your circle whether that's videos of
successful entrepreneurs being confident
it just rubs off onto you if you're
around people who are thinking big all
the time you're gonna automatically just
start thinking bigger if you're around
toxic negative complaining people you're
gonna end up being toxic a negative
thing complaining even if you don't want
to be just because that's what's in your
environment and so off you need to put
up a shield and say like don't infect me
don't come near me don't don't inject me
with your poison I don't want that
that's toxic to me and you may not be
able to escape all of that right like
maybe that's your mom who's telling you
you can't do things and that you suck
and you're never gonna be anything you
know it's hard to say I don't want to
talk to you ever again mom that may be
the end for some people but most you
know you want had some kind of
relationship so it's not necessarily
cutting everything off
completely it's limiting exposure right
so if your box is full you know like
it's full of negativity like limit that
exposure and then start increasing the
other side with other things with videos
with books with content if you find
somebody who you resonate with like if
you love my videos and subscribe to the
channel who watch the videos if you love
Will Smith and his messages and
subscribe to news alerts on Will Smith
and anytime he has a video that comes
out you're consuming it and start your
day with it and surround yourself with
it the more that you can be around
people like that even if only in an
aspirational way like you may never meet
Will Smith but consuming his content and
being around him by watching his videos
as much as possible now not not 24 hours
a day right yourself to do work but to
the phone where like it builds you up
then it allows you to have that stronger
shield against the negativity because at
some point if you don't have the
positive you're just gonna be
overwhelmed like you can only hold up
that shield for so long before those
goblins come and destroy you and they
break it down and then you're acting
like them and so the most important part
that's why I created this channel the
self belief that you can go off and do
amazing things that that idea that you
have inside your head is possible that
the story you're telling yourself as to
why you can't do it is just a story that
just because nobody around you has done
it before it doesn't mean that you can't
and invariably what I look at is all
these successful people that have done
massive things that you look up to you
look whoever you look up to look at Will
Smith look at any of these people that
you look up to and say wow that person's
accomplished so much look at where they
came from
look at how they started almost all of
them started with less than what you
already have right now less money and
less resources less connections less
opportunity like you're living in a much
greater error than any of these people
who got started and so they could do it
I remember when I first started studying
success I think I was thinking if they
can do it why can't I look if these
people can start with no money in a
worst generation no resources where the
worst upbringing than what I have why
can they do it and I can't and it made
me realize I can write like they can do
it I can do it too and it's not looking
at Will Smith now and the impact he can
have now and that's great and that's
something to aspire to but like how did
he get started and how do you build this
amazing career and have this huge in
and all the entrepreneur's that we
profile but they can do it you can too
you just have to believe that you're
capable
so the question date today is I'm
curious what is one thing that you used
to believe that you couldn't do and
you've changed that belief system around
to say I know I can do this I mean I've
done it yet but I know I'm capable of it
what is that thing for you write down
the comments below I hope that by
writing it down it'll help build up the
confidence in yourself to accomplishing
it as well as inspire other people who
are watching who may feel a little bit
of self-doubt seeing that flow of
positivity come out in the comments can
really be a source of inspiration for
others as well so please share your
thoughts down the comments below I also
want to give a quick shout out to Martin
Cupid Martin thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word it really really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the read
thank you guys again for watching I hope
you have an amazing day I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
I'm a believer bro I like I see things
and I want to make them real
no matter how how hard it takes no
matter what obstacles no matter how many
embarrassing meetings I have to imagine
is happening when I leave does it matter
I'm out doer and a freaking make it
happen early here's maybe the greatest
thing a teen or anyone in this room and
who's watching on the television at home
can learn from the champ these are words
to remember when anyone tries to tell
you to give up tell you to give in
because whatever you're trying to do is
impossible the champ said this
impossible is just a word thrown around
by a small men who find it easier to
live in the world they've been given
than to explore the power they have to
change it impossible is not a fact it's
an opinion impossible this potential
impossible is temporary impossible is
nothing greatest ever
so as a relatively new dad and a former
team I'm here to say you will make
mistakes
along the way you will fall down I have
many times even Ally did but what we do
after that fall is how we make history
because impossible is nothing I was in
Johannesburg a little while ago and I
went through the the airport and I went
into the men's room or washroom or
bathroom however you want to call it and
so I walked in it to the men's room and
the first thing I hear is welcome to my
office and this was the janitor at the
Johannesburg men's room that's funny
hoo-hoo janitor eyes door I'll make up a
word cleaned the men's the toilets like
Mozart composed music now that man has
no money that man probably has very
little education that man is judged by
the world as having an unimportant job
right and that man is a hero could be
here at a millions of people why because
he actually saw himself as an ambassador
to South Africa and his passion was was
palpable and his visceral commitment to
doing work at the highest level was like
you don't see even from the CEOs and all
I'm saying is even the person in the
with the broken heart the person who's
down on their knees whether they see it
or not they have a choice to rise above
their circumstances and leadership and
humanity is a testament to the people
who have done it I mean you read read
the group you look at Mandela you know
27 years in imprisonment when his son
died he wasn't allowed to attend the
funeral of his own son he said that was
the one of the great pains of his own of
his life and what did he do the victim
looks at something like that torture and
says I am broken and they give up and
they spend that they closed their heart
they closed their mind they closed their
creativity and they blame the rest of
their life on what happened to them but
Mandela what he chose to do was to use
it as an opportunity because actually
the things that break your heart if you
choose can open your heart and adver
fear the world says fear is bad fear is
only an opportunity for bravery training
and what he did was he used those 27
years of torture to open his himself
mentally physically emotionally and
spiritually to the point where when he
was released and became the president of
South Africa he invited his jailers to
sit in the front row at his inauguration
and he was asked why and he said because
if I don't I'm still gonna I'd still be
in prison and that's a long way of
saying but you know we do make excuses
because we are very good at
self-deception because if we actually
had to face the responsibility of
playing with our bigness in the world
we'd have to let go of our addiction to
our excuses and and leave what's safe am
i making sense only now you're talking
that you don't have to leave what's safe
I mean we are addicted to crisis
sometimes it makes no sense we are
addicted to pain and we'd have to
actually leave the pain to go out to the
possibility of pleasure and joy and
greatness and believe it or not that
frightens us right so we make these
excuses and then we blame people Oh Joe
or Robin I don't like the way he looks I
he he speaks differently but
subconsciously as you're suggesting
those are just our protective mechanisms
to avoid owning the responsibility of
our brilliance if you had to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or so it would be like
a little beacon hey believe nation if
you want to know what the most important
one word is for Tony Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details